First, you'll need to create
an Analytics account ID.
I'll walk you through this process, and
in the next node you'll do it yourself.
We start by going to
analytics.google.com.
If you're already logged in to Google,
you'll see the Access Google Analytics
button at the top right.
If your not already logged in,
you'll see a button for signing in.
I'm going to assume you already have a
Google account, but if not, go ahead and
create one now I'm going to sign in.
If you're new to Analytics,
you'll see a welcome screen.
Go ahead and sign up for Analytics.
You're going to be
tracking a mobile app.
And you need to enter an account name.
This can be whatever you like.
It's for you to identify the count.
It's a good practice to have the name
be something that relates your app,
then you need to setup the app name.
Analytics doesn't check that it
corresponds to a real app name, so
again, enter something helpful to you.
Go ahead and
fill in the rest of the form.
Choose an industry category.
Our sample app is to do with dinner,
I guess that would be food and drink.
My reporting time zone
is the United States.
States GMT Pacific Time.
Yours might be different.
And then also choose
the data sharing settings.
The first data sharing option is that
you can choose to share your data
with other Google products only.
And this means sharing the data
with your other accounts.
For example this let's you
import your Analytics data
into your AdWords account,
if you have one.
The next data sharing setting,
is that you can choose to share your
data anonymously with Google and others.
This basically just means
that your data will be shared
completely anonymized with Google, all
identifying information removed from it.
And Google will use the data for
marketing, educational purposes and
to make customized communications.
If you share your data
with technical support,
this helps us help you,
if you have technical difficulties.
The last sharing option is for
account specialists.
So if you share your data with account
specialists, this means that the Google
account specialist can look at your data
and help you optimize your strategies.
And you'll see at the bottom it tells
you how many accounts you're using.
For this user that I've logged in with,
I'm using 0 out of 100 accounts, so
this is going to be my first account.
So now, I'm going to get my tracking ID.
Accept the terms of service, assuming
you do accept them, and look yay.
I have a tracking ID.
So, this tracking ID is going to be
the link between your app and Analytics.
You'll add the count ID
to your mobile app code.
And then, when people use your app the
app will send usage data to Analytics
at this ID.